fresh back from uh being a correspondent
this week
where he made his hall of fame bones of
the vikings is pro football hall of
famer chris carter how are you chris
rich i'm doing very good how are you i
am doing fine um
the piece that's been put together uh
involving you tonight is moving it's
excellent and i can't wait for everyone
to have it and i'm
that's part of the reason why i want to
have you on is to to preview it um it's
personal
and many different ways for you and i
give you the floor on what you did for
the grind
in minnesota this week i'm well for one
rich as you know you've been associated
with the league in sports
and and sometimes you know you go from
generation to generation
and a very very high expectation level
of their wide receivers
long before i got there they had that
expectation
they continued through myself and
through randy moss we took a lot of
pride in that
it's like being a pittsburgh steelers
linebacker like there's certain things
certain characteristics
that you really feel like
you embraced those when you were there
and i believe that justin jefferson
will be under the radar underrated um
the wide receiver from
lsu last year he scored 22 touchdowns
um being one of many weapons on an
undefeated football team but seeing him
and kind of
passing the baton to him as a first
round draft pick
into that legacies the vikings and the
vikings this is not their best season
it's from a starting standpoint but he's
having a record-breaking
season uh nonetheless so um that's
a main part of the focus that's what
brings me to
to minneapolis to let the world see this
young talent
um i'll give you a name a guy just
inducted into the pro football hall of
fame
when you watch justin jefferson run
you'll see
a lot of our man
isaac bruce river knight wow you'll see
that
flashing that body type that long stride
quiet a real quiet assassin not
making media bows not being about
commercials and stuff like that but an
efficient route runner
tremendous in traffic 50 50 balls
like that's that's why i believe this
kid
that's where the ceiling is as far as
his career and then right now
minneapolis is a different
um than when i spent 12 years there in
my life
and people might forget 1990 when i did
go there rich
i went there with a lot of problems and
a lot of baggage
and the people from minnesota did
everything they could
to help me save my life and really give
me the power
that i can say now i'm 30 years sober 30
years off cocaine
because of minneapolis and the vikings
and the systems they gave
but after what we saw in george floyd
and everything that has come out all the
information i'm not that surprised
so i thought that i couldn't go back
there
to a place within it's within miles of
where i got my hair cut and sometimes we
go down on fridays as you know the ball
players do
and visit little local establishments
it's right there with places where we
used to go all the time
so i wanted to go there i wanted to fill
it
and it was far more
put together as far as what's at the
site what continues to be there
so it was a it was really a pleasure for
me um
doing the story on justin jefferson i'm
seeing what's going on in the world as
far as racial
inequalities and george floyd being
right there
has been that could have been my son
that could have been one of my teammates
that could have been one of my uncles so
for me i thought bringing some type of
light to that because we were there
and of course no one does it better than
nfl films i thought they would do it um
an exceptional job
and and wait to see it tonight uh chris
uh nine eastern
on epics and your daughter who's works
for the vikings was with you
and that just made it even more moving
uh that uh you were there together
what what is it like to be there uh what
because i it looks like that there is uh
some sort of arrangement and setup and
flowers and
i'm trying to describe it a little bit
for for the radio audience right now
chris
what what is it like to be at the spot
where george floyd was murdered
i would say it's a it's a living
memorial
um they blocked off the streets actually
there's a dispute between
the people the streets they blocked off
three blocks
they won't let traffic go through there
they police it themselves they have a
number of demands that they want from
from city government but they have it
all blocked off
they have candles they have a campfire
set up they have meetings seven in the
morning seven at night
there's fruits there's vegetables
growing people planted trees
around it people have painted murals
beautiful murals and everything
and they keep coming back and changing
them and upgrading them
so it's it's
it's more than where a man lost his life
and and to me you see that store right
there
and all this was over twenty dollars
and to see what the people have done to
memorialize that
and and to make us keep thinking about
it um
it's excellent and i was not
anticipating
all of that and so for me
i won't forget that day so i'm just glad
we were able to do it
and do it the right way and it's
memorialized by nfl films that'll be
tonight on nfl the grind uh on epics at
nine eastern time
uh returning to the to the football
aspect of why you were there
what what why are the vikings one and
four i mean what what
what gives i guess is the short uh
question on that front chris
well a couple of things this is a very
very unique year
and in the off season i was um
you know telling my circle of friends
and and people who would listen
you know this is a different year i
would give the edge to the veteran
coaches
but now that the season started
the veteran coaches i mean this is such
a different nfl as far as practice squad
players you can use
the lack of physicality the lack of
tackling
um man if you get an offensive lineman
or two hurt man you are you you might as
well you might as well phone it on in
you know so for me i think it's a more
even playing field
with some of the other coaches that
don't have as much experience i hope you
understand that rich
but i was i'm really shocked
at just how bad defenses are
like i'm just i'm really shocked i know
offensive football you can play it in
shorts
you can play it in a pandemic and with
the lack of a crowd
offensive football is so much easier
so um there's a few surprises for me as
far as the year and the
and the vikings they just haven't been
that good up front the last couple years
and they lost some key veteran players
because of salary cap
you know jefferson griffith you lose him
you know how much leadership goes out
with him
when dalvin cook is not playing we have
seen that through the years
they are a different football team and
they are just not as explosive as they
were on the defensive side of all
my our guy danielle uh danielle hunter
he's not playing might not play for the
year one of the best young pass rushers
there is
and um they're unable to get off the
field on third down so
i'm shocked that a mike zimmer
tough-minded physical
football team would be able to give up
as many points
and especially the lack of fight that
they had them in the falcons game on
sunday
and then there's the lack of consistency
i would say again from uh from the
quarterback um
who's as great a human there there is on
the planet and kirk cousins
but if we're just talking about a
quarterback here i mean
how do you go one week in seattle where
it's all pretty much on tilt and then
the next week
um you know several interceptions and a
passer rating that's in the teens i i
i don't get it i i i wonder what you can
shed light on here chris carter
well this is what you have to figure
when when you buy in the kirk cousins
you have to buy into there's going to be
some sundays
where he is going to be talent
challenged
because he doesn't have the greatest
dimensions in the world yeah he is a
nice guy
he is smart but as you know on sundays
when you don't have the overwhelming arm
count
or the overwhelming say explosive
offense around you where you're going to
do a lot of things to put a lot of
pressure on the defense
and you want to be a running football
team
guys don't have that much talent when
you have to throw the ball
you get down early i mean you you you
run a waggle boot to set the game up to
throw the ball to the rookie and you
throw
an interception like those kind of guys
they can't stop the bleeding as my man
steve young would say
you know you gotta know when the car is
crashed
and pull it over and stop the bleeding
and kirk cousin just does not have that
ability you know if you can run the ball
if you can do play action
if you can assist him give him a short
field have a good defense
multiple possessions on the turnover
like you're going to win the turnover
battle
yeah kirk cousins can get you into the
playoffs and that's what he has gotten
the vikings
and the vikings have paid the king's
ransom to be able to have a guy
that to me is at the top
he's only going to get you to the first
or second round of the playoffs
there's too many gunslingers there are
too many dominant quarterbacks
and too many great defensive fronts for
the vikings what's their weakness
that offensive line when you go against
the green bays and you go against the
san francisco's
the seattle and and all those teams
i mean it's hard to match up and then
you can't
outsling aaron rodgers russell wilson
like man it's difficult in the nfc but
that's my team man
and and that's just my perspective on my
team that i watch every week
chris carter uh pro football hall of
famer eight-time pro bowler here
on the rich eisen show what do you think
is going all right what's the challenge
now for the dolphins who as we as we
know
uncorked uh tour uh as the starter
they're in a bye week
um and again you mentioned uh rightfully
so
unique 2020 no otas no
training camp no preseason all they've
had is just with tua
is what they've had in practice and then
just that cup of coffee
at the end of the jets game when there
were hardly any starters out there on
the field with him what's the challenge
here to get him up to speed now
for a team that does have a shot at the
division chris
rich how many times have you because
you've been
at a lot of good networks and you work
with a lot of talented people
it takes about 15 minutes sometimes
somebody walks in the door
they say something to you and you're
like wow there's something different or
i thought this person was totally
different tua is a special
special human being and he is one of the
most accurate quarterbacks that we ever
had in college football
i look for him in the right environment
because
you know styles make fights in boxing in
the nfl
99 of us need a system tom brady need
the system
barry sanders didn't jim brown didn't lt
didn't but the rest of us do
all the hall of famers we talked about
michael irvin he needed this system kurt
warner needed that quick release
and guys running on the move this guy
in the right environment i believe the
dolphins in their organization i respect
what they're doing how they pick players
and i believe that they could build
something special in my hand
miami with tua because i believe he's
special and it's just a matter of time
when you get these kind of people in
your presence
it's a matter of time when they're going
to get their own show when they're going
to get their own gig
and to me when they drafted him at
number five it was the
the the the fans and the hourglass was
just starting to tip to
okay when is he gonna start in his
rookie year
and in terms of the first game uh
receivers
are irvin's talked to me about this too
about catching a ball from a lefty
it's a different thing right that's an
adjustment wouldn't you agree
or something like that yeah i learned
this from jerry rice when they switched
over from
from joe montana to steve young he got
one of the equipment guys
to learn how to throw left-handed and
they used to just play catch on the
other side
and then we used to have steve young in
the pro bowl his ball was totally
different than troy aikman
and the other guy so absolutely so
i believe especially with the bye week
and with him being in that number two
spot
being here for several months i believe
that will overcome that but
he throws a very very soft and a
catchable ball
all right just like steve young he's got
a little more
arm strength than steve young had
but it's the same type of thing that
type of accuracy
where the ball speaks to the receiver
people say well what is that
if you're running across the middle and
hit you on your back hip that means
there ain't green grass in front of you
slow down there's traffic out there
if he hits you in stride typically sam
run
so i believe he's a special i believe
you're going to see special special
thing
other two in miami dolphins uniform he
is the replacement to dan marino
they finally got it i feel the same way
i really do chris and i know that
uh you know we haven't seen anything yet
i get it professionally and we've seen
so many guys who
who come out of college with the
supposed hit factor and they just don't
i i agree with you i'm i'm i'm all in on
this i really i really really
am you know big time
and it's funny how you you know there
are certain people that are born for
certain things
and this kid is meant to be
true breeds was meant to lead the nfl
team
right well you know drew like he's like
this dude is a dudes dude
tua is the same way he's funny he's
charismatic
guys on the team love him like
he's got special special arm talent
before i let you go chris i i you know i
was going to ask you about cowboys and
other stuff but you mentioned something
just a couple minutes ago i i i got to
pull on this strand
so you say hall of famer sit around and
talk about systems and who needs it and
who doesn't and
i i mean like what is this at the
luncheon or you're just you know you're
getting ready to be introduced at the
jacket or
you know it's a long ass day listening
to speeches in between speeches i mean
you know walk me through when you have
these conversations and who sparks them
like how does something like that come
up
chris well you spend enough time with
the gold jackets man you know these guys
are not short on confidence yes i know
and regardless of what your stats were
they could duplicate that
um you know michael irvin him and i are
always talking it might
there's no one you can respect more in
the game but mike i swear up and down
i was in minnesota c i had 11 1200
catches
bro just right just like you boy i had
them wings
[Laughter]
perfect perfect no doubt
no doubt he believes that right no doubt
you haven't gone
oh so that's the sort of conversations
you guys have just get you just uh go
back and forth and then just in terms of
systems
you know marshall didn't need assistance
always tell
would you always tells me when i say my
prayers at night yeah
thank god that you were not born in the
70s
my mom wasn't ready chris i gotta be
honest with you you know as you
mentioned
i've been fortunate to be around the
hall since uh since before nfl network
was launched in 2003
the first time i laid eyes on mel blunt
i said to myself no wonder they had to
change the rules
i he he just kept going he just kept
going you know just looking up mel blunt
he just didn't
he just kept going up up up up and then
he puts that cowboy hat on top
and it looks like he can give you ten
snaps right now
really that guy and it's amazing like
him and me and joe green whatever
reputation they have
man when we come into the hall they take
us in like little brothers
and i mean they can't help but the
rebels all the time but
and to me these guys are my role models
in life
and i tell them man i want to be like
you after the game i want people to
respect me
you know 20 years from now the way they
respect them and talk about them so
they continue to be role models for us
younger
hall of famers and continue to set a
great example
you know for how we should conduct
ourselves as gold jackets
chris thanks for the call great to see
you on the grind tonight uh i think
you're going to love the piece
and um and let's do this again
absolutely rich take care man you don't
really thanks same to you that's chris
carter right here on the rich eisen show